R
FREAKING YOURSELF.
SO TIKTOK TURNS OUT TO BE BY
FAR, THE MOST POPULAR
SOCIAL MEDIA AFTER THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS, IT IS OWNED
BY A GIANT CHINESE COMPANY
CONTROLLED BY THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
AND IT IS FOR THAT REASON, A
MAJOR SECURITY RISK.
NOT ONLY DOES IT SHOW
PROPAGANDA, BUT IT ALSO
APPARENTLY IS FOR SPYING.
SO THE GOVERNMENTS IN A COUPLE
OF STATES HAVE ALREADY MOVED TO
BLOCK STUFF TICK-TOCK ON
GOVERNMENT DEVICES.
NOW A U.S. SENATOR FROM FLORIDA
HAS INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
BAN TIKTOK AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
SO, REPUBLICANS ARE GENERALLY
AGAINST BANNING PRIVATE
COMPANIES, THAT IS WHY WE SHOULD
BAN TIKTOK IF YOU WERE?
>> WE BAND THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE MONEY IN THE COUNTRY AND
THE REASON IS ITS CELL
SUBSIDIARY THE COMMUNIST PARTY
CHINA.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE CONTENT
ULTIMATELY, WE HAVE FREE SPEECH
BUT IT'S ABOUT THE DATA AND HOW
IS BEING USED.
PEOPLE MIGHT SAY TO ME WHAT WE
CARE IF THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
GATE OF THE FUN OF THE 60
TEENAGERS SOME AMERICANS.
IT IS NOT ABOUT THE 16-YEAR-OLD
TENANT NATURE, IT'S ABOUT
MILLIONS OF 16 OR 17 OR
30-YEAR-OLDS WHO ARE ON THEIR
DUMPING ALL KINDS OF DATA THAT
THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA GETS
ACCESS TO OUR LOCATION, PICTURES
OR TEXT YOUR CONSUMER BEHAVIOR,
WHAT THE ALGORITHM WAS FROM YOU
AND THEN THE OTHER FINGERS AND
THIS IS WAS STUNNING TO ME, THE
CHINESE TRY TO INTERFERE IN OUR
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THEY'RE PUTTING OUT VIDEOS TO
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE USING THE
ALGORITHMS TO DO THAT, TO
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE TO VOTE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I TELL PEOPLE,
IF TICK-TOCK WAS A RUSSIAN
COMPANY, THEY WOULD BE AN FBI
RAID OF THE HEADQUARTERS.
AT LEAST IT WOULD BE CALLING FOR
HER ON THE LEFT, SO I THINK
EVERYBODY AGREES THEIR PRIVACY
DANGER TO AMERICA ON A NATIONAL
SECURITY AND WE SHOULD NOT HAVE
THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA
HAVING ACCESS TO DATA ART THAT
THEY CAN TRY NEW STUDENT TO
INFLUENCE AND DIVIDE US AS THEY
COLLECT VALUABLE INFORMATION OUT
TO THE FUTURE.
>> Tucker Carlson: YEAH WE
BAND RT, AND I'M HOPING YOU'RE
GONNA GET AT LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT
ON YOUR SIDE IN THIS ARE YOU?
>> I THINK WE WILL.
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
DEMOCRAT SUPPORT FOR THE
CONCERN.
HUMAN HAS SENT A LETTER
TOGETHER, AS IN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE INTELLIGENT
AGENCY TO SPEED UP THE REVIEW, I
THINK ANYTHING'S IN A CONVENT.
I REALLY DON'T, AT THE END OF
THE DAY IF ANYTHING THINGS IN A
COME OF THE SECURITY REVIEW OR
ANYTHING THEY TOO WILL TAKE CARE
OF THIS PROBLEM.
I THINK WE HAVE TO BEGIN WITH
THE VERY BASIC PRINCIPLE,
COMPANIES ON THE POTENTIAL OF
THE COMMUNIST PARTY SHOULD NOT
HAVE ACCESS AND UNFETTERED
ACCESS TO THE PRIVATE DATA OF
MILLIONS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS THAT THEY CAN CAN USE
AGAINST US.
FOR A SPIN OFF, FOR FOREIGN
POLICY.
>> Tucker Carlson: THANK YOU